three months after suffering a broken  heart by losing his wife Beth his heart  is now threatening his life today he  told us about being diagnosed with a  pulmonary embolism or blood clots in the  arteries  next step is blood thinners 98% of blood  thinners work hard no blood clot the  condition was discovered after being  rushed to the hospital around two and a  half weeks ago the 66 year old is now  working on quitting smoking  I ordered the nicotine patch this  afternoon  Kevin sat down with the Bounty Hunter in  July just days after losing Beth to  cancer dog said he did not fear death  are you ready to go because you want to  join that wall of course yeah I'm ready  you know yeah oh yeah I said you beat me  to this you say that right out through  the new someone and then when it comes  down to the nitty-gritty survival takes  over I'd rather live  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]